mais en début de semaine Emmanuel Macron
a redit sa volonté de mettre en chantier
je le cite une loi efficace et juste en
un seul texte sur l'immigration quel
contour selon vous doit avoir ce texte
cette loi et est-ce que vous êtes prêt à
le co-construire avec la majorité
est-ce qu'il s'agit d'un énième filet
d'eau tiède en matière d'immigration 21
lois adoptées au cours des années
écoulées et une situation qui connue et
qui continue de se dégrader 500
000 étrangers en situation régulière ont
été accueillis en France légalement
l'année dernière sans compter les 700 à
800 000 peut-être un million qui s'y
trouve sans compter les mineurs isolés
étrangers les clandestins mineurs donc
on est dans une situation d'urgence
absolue en matière d'immigration ce
qu'il faut c'est changer de cadre il
faut une révolution en matière de
politique migratoire il faut des quotas
il faut plus aucun droit pour les
clandestins plus aucun plus de
prestations sociales dès le premier jour
pour les réguliers il faut qu'on traite
les demandes d'asile à la frontière il
faut arrêter le regroupement familial
revoir le code de la nationalité est-ce
que Monsieur Macron est prêt à inscrire
tout cela par la loi j'en doute et je
doute aussi qu'on est la capacité au
Parlement à faire adopter un texte
compte tenu même des oppositions dans la
majorité donc j'ai une solution une
proposition il faut un référendum pour
changer de cadre ça fait des années que
nous le réclamons que je le question
quelle question poserait aux Français il
faudra un référendum qui modifie notre
Constitution qui modifie nos engagements
conventionnels notamment la Convention
européenne des droits de l'homme qui
parmi qui permet qui autorise le
regroupement familial avec son article 8
tout cela il faut changer de cadre et la
France
à sortir de cette Convention européenne
des droits de l'homme en tout cas de cet
article ça modification qu'il y ait des
réserves d'interprétation on ne peut pas
rester dans cette situation où on subit
une vague migratoire je la vis au
quotidien dans le département des
Alpes-Maritimes depuis quelques jours
depuis quelques semaines on subit une
véritable submersion sans réelle
réaction des pouvoirs publics je le
déplore il n'y a plus de contrôle à la
frontière franco-italienne il y a plus
de force mobiles et on a aujourd'hui le
nombre des mineurs clandestins qui a été
quasiment doublé depuis décembre il a
fallu que une structure dimanche les
mineurs clandestins sont à la charge du
département
des Alpes-Maritimes un minima de 15
millions d'euros d'ailleurs l'État
devrait assumer cette compétence c'est
un scandale que ce soit les
collectivités qui n'ont pas de pouvoir
réglementaire ou législatif pour assumer
cette charge et puis il y a une naïveté
incroyable pourquoi on accepte ces
mineurs pourquoi on ne les renvoie pas
immédiatement dans les pays d'origine où
ils ont une famille ce n'est pas la
France d'assumer la responsabilités
il faut avoir une action diplomatique
beaucoup plus déterminée beaucoup plus
coercitive moi j'irai au Maroc la
semaine dernière prochaine avec une
délégation de républicains nous
porterons ce débat cette revanche on a
un exemple chimiquement pur de cette
situation c'est un Mayotte où on voit
que l'opération qui a été menée par
Gérald Darmanin qui défend une action
visant la restauration de la paix
républicaine ne se passe pas comme il
faut tout simplement parce que les îles
et l'archipel des Comores refusent de
récupérer ces ces ressortissants comment
on fait concrètement là il y a des
moyens de pression à mettre en œuvre sur
les Comores
on a accordé une aide au développement
de 120 millions d'euros Comores c'est un
moyen il faut discuter il faut dire on
ne peut pas vous donner de l'argent et
refuser de reprendre des ressourcissants
qui sont arrivés à Mayotte de façon
clandestine irrégulière je crois que ce
soit en cours en ce moment entre les
deux pays de visa aussi la France
accorde beaucoup de visa aux comorien
qui vit qui viennent en France et bien
il faut comme sur les pays du Maghreb
ouvrir le débat sur les visas il faut
qu'il y ait une réciprocité dans les
droits et de voir la France ne peut pas
avoir que des devoirs les pays sources
d'immigration doivent prendre leur
responsabilité et on doit avec fermeté
leur rappeler dans un dialogue équilibré
vous préconisez que la France arrête ou
tête public au développement et à l'État
aux États Comoriens tant que une
solution n'a pas été trouvée et qu'on
arrête de donner comme ça des visas un
peu à n'importe quelle pièce
ressortissants qui les réclame si les
Comores refusent de reprendre leur
ressortissant c'est naturellement la
voix qu'il faut adopter mais je souligne
que cette opération bambouchou et la
bienvenue et je soutiens le ministre de
l'Intérieur dans sa démarche c'est pas
un échec pour lui d'avoir été cette
opération
par le député républicain Mansour
camardine depuis plusieurs années
c'est une situation insupportable et ce
qui se passe le tribunal judiciaire de
Mayotte interdit la destruction des des
bidons villes est-ce que c'est un échec
pour Gérald Darmanin où est-ce que
finalement on appelle on finira par
obtenir gain de cause comme j'ai souvent
le cas en France j'ai vu que le préfet
avait fait appel de cette décision et il
y a ces contraintes que personnellement
je ne comprends pas en tout cas je
souhaite personnellement je le dis je
soutiens cette opération qu'elle aille
au bout et qu'elle ne traduise pas la
faiblesse de la France mais ceux qui se
passe à Mayotte et un signal pour nous
parce que demain cela peut se passer en
métropole on voit des territoires
aujourd'hui qui sont gangrenés par une
situation de délinquance qui souvent
trouve sa source aussi dans les graines
que le ministre l'a dit donc il faut
agir avant qu'il ne soit trop tard vous
dites qu'il y a des départements en
France métropolitaine je veux dire
autour de Paris Lyon Marseille est
peut-être Nice qui pourrait être des
petits Mayotte dans les mois les années
à venir en tout cas on a une vague
migratoire qui s'annonce on voit bien ce
qui se passe en Tunisie aujourd'hui qui
chasse les Africains
les étrangers d'origine subsaharienne
d'Afrique subsaharienne les arrivées en
Italie ont été multipliés par 5 depuis
le début de l'année par rapport à 2022
donc la vague migratoire elle est là il
faut agir et il pourragir il faut une
volonté très nettement supérieure à
celle qui s'exprime aujourd'hui je le
redis jamais nous n'avons accueilli dans
l'histoire de France autant d'étrangers
qu'en 2022 c'est le record absolu cela
n'est plutôt l'érable cela n'est plus
supportable autre sujet avec cioti hier
à ce micro rachète adaptique et mère et
l'air du 7e arrondissement est revenu
sur la volonté du ministre de
l'Éducation pas bendiaye de vouloir plus
de mixité dans les écoles privées
pourquoi veut-il détruire ce qu'il
marche c'était à l'armée est-ce que vous
un peu sur cette ligne de conduite bien
sûr j'ai publié hier une tribu dans le
Figaro pour dénoncer la volonté de
monsieur papendiere qui a des
complaisances avec le mot quiisme dans
son histoire personnelle je le dis
d'ailleurs ces propos le confirme qui
est l'inverse de ce qui était
Jean-Michel Jean-Michel
il a nié à l'université une démarche
islamo-gauchistes ils disent ça n'existe
pas c'est des travaux de recherche il a
accusé la France d'avoir un modèle
républicain très très affaibli il a
parlé de racisme systémique pour notre
pays tout ça ce sont des ce sont des
éléments qui me m'inquiète par rapport à
la capacité de ce ministre à défendre la
laïcité républicaine il porte atteinte
au Conseil des Sages sur la laïcité
Michael Patty la sœur de Samuel Paty la
dénoncé en des termes très très forts et
très et très puissant et là il s'attaque
à l'école libre il réouvre la guerre
scolaire exactement
alors que l'école aujourd'hui
républicaine l'école publique s'effondre
soumise à la violence au manque
d'autorité que le niveau de nos élèves
aujourd'hui suit une pente
extraordinairement dangereuse que 40%
des élèves 30 ans que l'école ce weekend
chute
40% des élèves qui maîtrisent mal la
lecture en rentrant en 6e alors qu'il y
a urgence alors que comme aurait dit
Jacques Chirac sur l'environnement la
maison brûle le ministre de l'Éducation
regarde d'ailleurs il regarde il prend
pour cible l'enseignement privé
l'enseignement catholique mais c'est
totalement ahurissant il y a t-il pas
d'autres priorités
faut remonter le niveau il faut
s'attaquer aux carences en lecture en
mathématiques il faut remettre de
l'autorité redonner de l'autorité aux
enseignants qui sont victimes
d'agression en classe non le ministre
choisit de s'attaquer à l'enseignement
libre sous motif qu'il n'y aurait pas
suffisamment de mixité sociale
l'enseignement libre fonctionne
aujourd'hui c'est un refuge pour
beaucoup de familles et on veut attaquer
ce qui fonctionne plutôt que sauver ce
qui ne fonctionne plus est-ce que vous
êtes inquiet Eric ce type de
l'incapacité du président d'une partie
de son gouvernement a sorti de Paris
aller à la rencontre des Français est-ce
que c'est le symbole le signe d'un état
paralysé aujourd'hui il y a cette crise
politique qui
menace le fonctionnement même de nos
institutions elle est là le président de
la République fait de la communication
on voit bien dans ces étranges
déplacements
successifs
c'est à lui de le décider est important
c'est qu'il retrouve un fil de confiance
avec les Français aujourd'hui
manifestement il est rompu même si je le
redis et je le dis en responsabilité sur
cette question des retraites j'ai
personnellement soutenu cette réforme
dans un esprit de cohérence vous étiez
non uneanime nous n'étions pas une amie
c'est le cas mais le Bureau politique
des républicains à la quasi unanimité a
soutenue cette réforme les sénateurs
l'ont soutenu une majorité une majorité
de députés la soutenu pourquoi parce
qu'elle était nécessaire pour le pays et
parce que nous sommes partis de
gouvernement un parti de responsabilité
mais aujourd'hui les Français expriment
une colère beaucoup plus générale
justement à après cette affaire des
retraites il y a cette ce malaise dans
le pays il y a des problématiques liées
au pouvoir d'achat on a des salaires
trop on a des instants sur les retraites
comment la droite les républicains
peuvent se relancer on a vu que vous
étiez pas forcément totalement alignés
sur des questions importantes comme les
retraites que pourtant vous appeliez de
vos vœux il y a quelques années est-ce
qu'il faut faire il faut changer de
dirigeant déjà vous êtes en poste depuis
4 mois et demi est-ce qu'il faut une
nouvelle doctrine est-ce qu'il faut
penser à ce que seront les républicains
dans 4 ans ou dans 15 ans moi mon
objectif c'est que nous gagnons
l'élection présidentielle de 2027 vous y
croyez vraiment j'y crois vraiment et
toute mon action toute mon énergie est
placée vers cet objectif voilà
aujourd'hui il peut paraître très
aléatoire mais nous y travaillons nous
lançons les États généraux je vous
l'annonce qu'il tiendront le 10 juin
prochain les états généraux de la droite
avec la France trouver un candidat
doctrine avec un objectif de poser notre
ligne idéologique alors très clairement
nous aurons six mois de
travail nous allons accueillir des
intellectuels nous allons ouvrir des
débats dans les fédérations qu'est-ce
que la droite qu'est-ce qu'elle veut
qu'est-ce qu'elle peut porter qu'est-ce
qu'elle doit porter comme espérance pour
le pays en tout cas
c'est toujours l'homme de la situation
où d'autres frappent à la porte c'est
pour moi en tout cas celui qui a le plus
de qualité pour relever ce défi pas
forcément de courage quand il s'agit de
monter au front pour faire voter les
députés LR pour une réforme qu'il
appelle ses vœux quelques mois avant il
a il a dit les choses clairement mais je
veux souligner qu'on lance un média
aussi la semaine prochaine
une certaine idée on lance une académie
de formation on va mettre en place un
compte recouvernement pour porter aussi
des propositions différentes par rapport
à ce qui est fait aujourd'hui donc on a
un calendrier très intense très dense
pour redresser la droite je suis bien
conscient que notre famille politique
est en difficulté que le débat sur les
retraites à souligner malheureusement
par rapport à des trajectoires
individuels et personnelles des
incohérences même si très
majoritairement je le redis nous avions
porté cette volonté de réformes parce
que le pays a besoin de réforme on ne
peut pas continuer à vivre à crédit on
ne peut pas continuer à dévaloriser le
travail tous nos partenaires européens
nous regardent la droite
opérations les finances publiques se
dégradent depuis 35 ans 40 ans en France
et que ce soit des gouvernements de
droite ou de gauche la trajectoire est
la même je ne le crois pas et les
chiffres le démontrent même si la
dernière fois où nous avons été au
pouvoir nous avons fait face à une crise
manifestement la pire depuis 1929 mais
nous avons rétabli de façon beaucoup
plus ferme les finances publiques même
si aujourd'hui je crois que c'est là
encore une véritable révolution qu'il
faut porter il faut que l'État soit plus
fort là où il est aujourd'hui
squelettique pour la sécurité pour
l'immigration pour la justice et il faut
qu'il soit plus allégé là où il a
empêche les Français travailler là où il
y a des dépenses sociales qui ont
atteint des niveaux abyssaux et qui
conduisent